la justicia no tiene fecha de caducidad
eso es lo que dice el abogado thomas
walter a quienes le preguntan sobre el
juicio contra los últimos nazis vivos es
el representando a los descendientes de
las víctimas del holocausto en el juicio
de un hombre de 100 años conocido como
joseph s en el banquillo de los acusados
por su papel en el asesinato de miles de
personas hace más de 70 años
este juicio es el juicio de la justicia
tardía también es tardío porque la
justicia alemana ha descuidado durante
décadas los juicios de los antiguos
nazis y no se interesó por procesar a
los criminales
el hombre que se enfrenta a los cargos
eran guardián sachsenhausen a las
afueras de berlín abierto en
1936 fue uno de los primeros campos de
concentración nazis donde se formaron
muchos oficiales de las fuerzas de
combate josep ese trabajo allí entre
1942 y 1945 haciendo guardia en una
torre de vigilancia se le acusa de haber
disparado contra prisioneros de guerra
soviéticos así como de haber matado a
reclusos utilizando ciclón ve el gas
venenoso utilizado para asesinar a
millones de judíos durante ese período
para antoine grumbach cuyo padre
falleció allí esta complicidad
constituye un crimen contra la humanidad
alumnos no sólo se le ataca a él sino a
todos esos innumerables guardias de los
campos que se comportaron de forma
inaceptable y fueron digan lo que digan
cómplices en los últimos años los
fiscales alemanes han perseguido a
varios adultos mayores que contribuyeron
directa o indirectamente al proyecto de
exterminio de los nazis incluida una
mujer de 96 años que la semana pasada
intentó huir de la justicia en el último
momento fue detenida rápidamente y su
juicio se reanudará a finales de este
mes